este programa busca acabar con las
bandas criminales que todos los años
transportan de manera ilegal a cientos
de personas y que ponen en riesgo sus
vidas para llegar aquí al reino unido-
justamente oa partir de hoy ha dicho el
gobierno de la marina británica
patrullará y evitará la llegada de
emigrantes por el canal de la mancha ha
dicho el gobierno que serán devueltos a
sus países de origen o los hombres
jóvenes es lo que se ha dicho hasta el
momento serán enviados a ruanda en
áfrica para procesar sus solicitudes de
asilo si son elegibles para ello el
primer ministro ha dicho desde que entre
uno de los puertos donde llegan estos
migrantes es que serán enviados todas
las personas que han llegado a este país
a partir del primero de enero de este
2002 y según las cifras cerca de cinco
mil personas han cruzado el canal de la
mancha de manera ilegal